- It's the 25th anniversary
of Selena's passing.
So what did you learn about
yourself playing Selena?
- Yeah, a lot.
I also struggled with the
language like she did.
She learned it as a young woman.
And my grandparents came here from Mexico,
and I grew up in a
Spanish-speaking household,
but my language was never perfect.
And that was a small
insecurity of mine, you know?
It made me feel somehow like
less a part of my culture.
And I realize now as an adult
that it doesn't matter
how far you are away
from your culture, there's
always time to reconnect,
and it doesn't rob you
of anything that you are.
- Yeah.
- So I was so proud
to play this woman, to
be filming in Mexico,
to be surrounded by my
culture, the language,
and be able to like get better
at it as she got better at it
during our show was really interesting.
And it was my first opportunity
to really lead a show
and have that much responsibility.
And I learned so much about business
and how I wanna go into
my next project, too,
because she was such an inspiration
when it came to being strong
but also being incredibly graceful.
- [Kelly] Yeah, being a great leader.
- [Christian] Yeah.
- I heard that even
Jennifer Lopez has mentioned
that she's excited for the series.
So how does that make you feel?
'Cause I remember when she played Selena,
I was like, "Oh, my God, J.Lo."
I was a fan since she
was like a Fly Girl, so.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, so I was very excited.
But I think what's cool about it is,
and what she's probably excited about,
is this is a whole new generation
that might not even know Selena.
You know what I'm saying?
- Yeah.
- And it's a shame.
And it's really cool that you're doing it
and paying tribute to this icon.
Were you excited that
she was excited about it?
- Yeah, I didn't see that coming at all.
And I-
- Yeah?
She's so sweet.
- I hear that, yeah.
- Yeah, yeah.
- And I'm such a fan of hers
and grew up watching that movie.
That movie was...
I know that movie backwards and forwards,
and she did such an
amazing job playing Selena,
which gives me a lot more pressure
'cause not only am I
stepping into Selena's shoes,
but I'm having to follow in
the footsteps of Jennifer.
But I was so happy when I saw that.
I saw it on social media
with everybody else.
I didn't know that was coming.
- That's cool.
- And it was
really heartwarming, yeah.
- Yeah, that makes you feel good.
It makes you feel confident
about what you're doing.